what do we make about what the speaker
said yesterday
well i'm not surprised what the speaker
said i i witnessed this incident uh it
took place the other day from my
office it was unpleasant it was
threatening
it was aggressive
uh but the truth is
the longer you and i are talking about
this in a way that's what boris johnson
wants
so why oh
because i think he wants to continue
this debate i think he's quite happy
with his scoreless rumor
being spread around
and actually
what i'd rather be talking about of
course you can ask whatever you want but
there's a lot going on in the world
we've got
high energy prices we've got the
story on nhs waiting list that was
announced yesterday where people
are waiting much longer for treatment
we've got major issues with fraud and
crime that we're talking about today and
to be honest
that's what we want to focus on rather
than
continue the debate about what happened
on monday unpleasant as it was although
doesn't it reflect for my viewers this
morning on on the level of where british
politics is at the moment in 21st
century britain when somebody slurs
somebody else and won't say sorry
it does it is a reflection of that and
tone comes from the top and the prime
minister
uh may want to reflect on that but i
don't think he's a very reflective man
so
i think uh he's probably
deep down not too unhappy that this is
now in its second week or third week or
whatever it is
and
in terms of its impact on politics
some of that's down to us
we can choose to be distracted by the
darker corners of the internet or we can
actually focus on things that affect
people's lives
and for my constituents right now
what they're worried about is energy
bills going up by 700 pounds
nhs waiting lists where people are being
told they might have to wait a year or
even two years for a hip or a knee
replacement these are the issues that
for all of us in politics we've got to
focus on
not just things that are thrown out
there designed to attract as much debate
confrontation and discussion as possible
and i'll come to those but i do want to
make the point that it's not just um the
prime minister whose slowest people you
know john mcdonnell refused to apologize
uh for talking about lynching esther
mcveigh angela rainer eventually
apologized for calling um the other side
tori scum chris brown apologize for
saying a rude word um to lindsey hoyle
in december and david lammy compared the
erg to nazis
well look
with all of those if you take the angela
raynor
thing for example
she made a mistake
and
many of us will make mistakes in life i
might make mistakes in life but it's how
we respond to those that matters and she
stood up afterwards and said i'm sorry i
got this wrong and that's what people do
and if people reflect on the mistakes
and do that that's one thing
i don't think we'll see that from the
prime minister because
everything that they've been saying for
the last couple of days in number 10 is
they don't feel any shame about this
they're not likely to apologize and they
want to leave it where it is right now
we've all got to reflect on how we talk
in politics there may be a day when i'm
in here okay and you're saying you said
something wrong pat i hope when that
happens i'll reflect on it uh and do the
right thing um but to be honest in prime
minister's questions today i'll be
surprised if the prime minister does
that yeah uh it's yeah say sorry you
know just so sorry and then everyone can
move on i'm just hearing that julian
keegan health minister tested positive
and carried on with the meeting thoughts
on that
um well
i think if you test positive you should
probably go home um i tested this
morning i'm negative yeah me too we're
doing it every day yeah um
you know we
i think after two years maybe people are
a bit weary of this and i understand
that but still if you test positive best
thing to do is go home in line with the
rules yeah um hindsight's a wonderful
thing i know um let's talk about the
windfall tax on oil and gas profits
that's what labour is calling for we
were chatting to the former pensions
minister earlier on um
and resortment and she was saying that
that could impact if that happens that
windfall tax it could impact on the
shareholders who are potentially
funds for pension funds for pensioners
well these companies are enjoying huge
profits if you look at bp's profits
yesterday
about 13 billion dollars shell last week
20 billion dollars the head of bp
described the current market as a cash
machine for his company
we think it's only right and fair that
when
the public
is facing bills going up by 700 pounds
over the coming year they could go up
even more in october that might not be
the end of it that the companies making
the most
out of this enormous spike in gas prices
uh pays some contribution to helping out
the consumers who pay for these products
we think that's right and fair and then
the light of these products also
affordable so we should penalize them
from being successful i wouldn't say
it's penalizing them i think it's about
fairness
and the cost of this shouldn't lie
entirely
with
the consumers of gas and electricity the
companies making the most out of this
should be asked to pay some contribution
towards it it would actually be a small
proportion of their profits but right
now they're not being asked to pay a
penny extra despite these enormous rises
in prices that consumers are feeling
okay good to talk to you as always
thanks for joining us thank you